عادةً ما يُعهد إلى الخبراء بالتخطيط والبناء ،
ولكن ماذا عن الأشخاص الذين قد
يعيشون هنا بالفعل ،
ما الذي يعتقدون أنه يجب أن يبدو مثل
[موسيقى
] أتخيل أنه مكان جميل في
المدن المستقبلية التي سنحصل عليها مثل
العائمة  مباني السيارات
والمزيد من التقنيات ،
ربما نحب أن نبتكر اختراعًا
يمكنه تنظيف المحيط ،
فربما يقود الأطفال السيارات
يومًا ما في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
لا أعرف شيئًا عن ذلك
ولكن من المهم الحصول على وجهات نظر هؤلاء الأطفال
بعد كل شيء  سيعيشون في
المدن التي يتم التخطيط لها اليوم ،
يزور هذا الفصل معرض دبي
للتعلم عن
الابتكارات والأفكار التكنولوجية التي يمكن أن ترفع
مستوى معيشتنا ، واحد اثنان
ثلاثة أشياء من هذه الأحداث الضخمة
غيرت مستقبلنا
ولكن ماذا عن
لقد ساعدت الأماكن الفعلية في دفعنا إلى الأمام ،
كما ترى عبر مواقع المعارض المختلفة ،
هناك العديد من المشكلات المتعلقة
بالمواقع الشاغرة والأحلام غير المحققة التي
لا تستطيع دبي دعمها  د لترك هذه
المساحة تذهب
سدى ، تخطط المدينة لمضاعفة
عدد سكانها تقريبًا في العشرين عامًا القادمة ،
لذا فإن الاستخدام الجيد لهذه المنطقة ليس
مجرد أمر لا بد منه ولكن لحظة لاختبار
طرق العيش المستقبلية
في أكتوبر ، فإن هذا الموقع سوف  إعادة فتح وإعادة
تسمية منطقة 2020 وقد يطلق ما يصل إلى 145000 من
السكان على هذا المكان
أكثر من 85 بالمائة من جميع
المباني التي تراها
والبنية التحتية باقية بالفعل ،
لذلك نحن لا نزيل أيًا من تلك
المباني
بعد انتقال المعرض إلى ahmed el-  الخطيب
هو كبير مسؤولي التوصيل في إكسبو
منذ ما يقرب من عقد من الزمان ، وكان
مسؤولاً عن تخطيط وتصميم
كل التفاصيل في الموقع من حجم
وشكل المباني إلى أنواع
الأشجار والزهور ، وحتى
المقاعد ، فهي تعكس في الواقع
نصًا عربيًا
مقاعدنا في الواقع يمكنك قراءتها ،
كان التحدي الأكبر لأحمد
وفريقه لم يكن يصمم مكانًا لنا
للجلوس ، بل كان إنشاء موقع كان
ممتعًا ذكيًا ولكن الأهم من ذلك أنه
مستدام  سنوات قادمة
للقيام بذلك ، كان عليه تحقيق بعض
الأهداف الطموحة جدًا أو ما يسميه الخبراء
مؤشرات الأداء الرئيسية لـ KPIS
التي أعجبنا بها
حوالي 41 كيلو بايت في الاستدامة ،
اعتقدت أننا سنقوم بنصفها ونحن فخورون جدًا
بأننا
حققنا جميع مؤشرات الأداء الرئيسية الخاصة بنا  وجميع ملفات kpis الخاصة بنا
تتم مراقبتها فعليًا من
قبل أطراف ثالثة والتحقق منها
واعتمادها ،
لذا
تم تحقيق أهدافنا بنتائج ملموسة للغاية ، وكانت
بعض هذه النتائج تضمن
وصول الموقع إلى وسائل نقل منخفضة الكربون
وحلول فعالة لإدارة النفايات من
خلال تحقيق هذه الأهداف
يعتقد منظمو إكسبو المنطقة  يمكن أن يكون عام 2020
مكانًا للاختبار ليس فقط للإمارات العربية المتحدة
ولكن بالنسبة إلى 192 دولة تعرض
هنا
ويبدو أنها تسير على الطريق الصحيح مع ما
يعتقد الأطفال أن المستقبل سيحمله ، نحتاج
إلى البدء في استخدام الأشياء التي لن تنفد أبدًا ،
نحتاج إلى البدء في زراعة الأشجار  نظرًا لأنه
ليس لدينا الكثير ،
نعم المزيد من الأشجار ، فهذا مفيد للعالم
ومثله يمنحنا أكسجينًا أفضل ،
أعتقد أنه يمكننا أن نتفق جميعًا على أن الأكسجين
هو  شرط أساسي مهم جدًا لأي
مدينة
ولكن كيف ستبدو المباني
المستدامة وكيف سننتقل من أ إلى ب
، فلنتابع هؤلاء الطلاب لمعرفة ما إذا كانت
المنطقة التعليمية 2020 لديها الإجابات
[موسيقى]